let's uh go to the doc who joins us now
the ncaa's chief medical officer
clinical professor of neurology at
indiana university's school of medicine
uh doc good morning thanks for joining
us
uh help me understand those quotes uh
when you
came up with that bottom line is this
all sports that we can't
safely play sports and the students come
back uh would be the downfall
well it was a reference to playing
sports today yes if we look at the
current environment the national
environment and especially we're
testing our testing paradigm and contact
tracing
it's not good today and what we don't
know is once the students start
re-socializing in the dorms and what
that brings to a college community
we have to be able to understand that so
it was really speaking about the moment
but then you see where the big 12 and
the acc and sec are playing football
how is that possible well so what's
happened is that
they decided to postpone and not make a
decision yet so
the way the ncaa works and it's it's not
such a straightforward organization
because it's a representative democracy
as
as you probably know so the autonomy
five schools really the fbi schools
they control the football the college
football championship
and so they have to adhere to mandates
that the ncaa put out because the ncaa
does oversee what happens with the
student athlete so
the we've been working actually i i was
a part of the member of the autonomy
five medical advisory panel their
guidelines are the exact same as ours
we put out the mandates but
independently the big ten made a
decision separate from the other four
then the pac-12 made a decision separate
from the other four and then the three
other conferences
said well we're postponing making a
decision so
um they date but when they make a
decision it must follow the mandates
that are in the third document that we
put out
we put out three documents over the last
two and a half months that have guided
how the membership can return to sport
but if you're saying that we can't have
football we can't have sports
uh we can't safely play sports and the
sec
acc and big 12 go ahead what happens
well again my reference was at the
moment i was really making a particular
point about what's been happening with
testing in this country
the fact that we don't have national
oversight a month from now
when they're contemplating possibly
beginning their schedule
we'll see where we are but they have to
follow the mandates in place and
and so that would set up a confrontation
if the mandates aren't being followed
what do you mean confrontation well on
the one hand the board of governors
which is the most powerful committed the
ncaa they've said
every school must follow these mandates
and so
um all of the conferences all the
individual schools must follow that and
so
you know that what what the
confrontation would be and you know i
can't predict what would happen with
that but but that's where things have
been laid out
what's the most important part of this
testing on a daily basis
for these athletes well you know
testing is just one part of it the most
important aspect of what can happen
is how athletes and everyone else behave
because you can be tested five times a
day
but if you're engaged in and risky
behavior
either on the field or off the field it
doesn't matter
but the one thing that testing allows
and especially if you have rapid
turnaround
is you can immediately isolate those who
have tested positive you can immediately
quarantine those who are in a very high
risk contact and so
that's a paradigm that really could make
sense for this country
it actually would be as effective as a
vaccine if we did it right
but right now where we are in this
country we still have a national
shortage of the reagent for
for the standard test pcr and in many
parts of the country it's
taking seven to ten days that's
essentially a worthless test
where are we on the vaccine feels like
they're at least a
window of opportunity here well there
there may be it's interesting i was on a
conference called uh the other day with
uh dr carlos del rio from emory who's
pretty world renowned and
understanding these issues and for the
first time he expressed some cautious
optimism that
we may have a vaccine roll out sometime
in in march or april
and again the rollout is it takes time
because
you know it means that you first work
with those that are really essential
workers
we have to decide who that is to find
that it's really you know our medical
workers the police but but also those
who are working in supermarkets and
doing essential jobs but
it would be a roll out over many months
if we reach that time
and doc i was wondering about this and i
know you mentioned this with students
coming back
on campus it feels like this the athlete
is
safer on campus given all the testing
than
if they they were back home or you know
in the general population there on
campus but now you bring that general
population
in and just the exposure and the nature
of being a college student
i just don't know how this i don't know
how this happens
i don't know how we pull this off i
really don't
well you're not alone in that thought so
um but you look at some schools for
example uh university of kentucky they
they just have a marvelous plan which
they
essentially created a semi-permeable
almost a real bubble effect with how
they're working with their entire
population of students
student athletes all of the other
stakeholders the teachers the
those the maintenance staff you know and
and and so that's
one model but um the other motto is okay
what what happens to the athletes i
think for the four hours a day that the
the schools are with them
yeah they can control their behavior but
the other 20 hours it's an unknown and
so
you know what does it mean to be a you
know a college kid and being in a
dormitory and that could be a higher
risk
behavior than than actually being in in
athletics so that that's the
that's the dilemma right now and that's
really the dilemma of being a student
athlete compared to being a professional
athlete
i keep hearing the word liability and i
feel like if i'm a president
at the big ten or pac-12 liability
played a larger role a large role in
our decision to shut things down would
you say that that is
the biggest concern here with presidents
as far as the ncaa goes
well look i've spoken to hundreds of
presidents and and they don't use the
word liability so much as they use the
word
the uncertainty and and what's feasible
and and how do we really
do the best thing for everyone in this
situation you know liability has been
thrown around
a lot and and so i'm sure there are
plaintiffs lawyers who are circling as
they always are for for any opportunity
but
but we're in the middle of a pandemic
and and and
the entire country needs to awaken and
say what can each one of us do
individually to do the right thing and
so yeah liability is one part of it but
i think it goes way way beyond that
what do you think of the nfl's plan
well we'll see you know so i'm in very
regular contact with all of the chief
medical officers of professional sports
so the nfl plan is very different for
example than the nhl and the mba which
have created a bubble and
and we'll see you know they moved from
three times a week testing to
essentially daily testing but again
what are the nfl players going to be
doing off the field and
and so you know the nfl plan in some
ways is not too different than major
league baseball and and so again you're
interacting with society is everyone
really taking that honor pledge and
doing the right thing
that remains to be seen and i wonder if
the ncaa
can you bubbalize college basketball
is is that possible
well so there are talks about that and
and and it depends what you mean and
and so as we move into say march madness
the final four i think there
there have already been uh conversations
about creating a bubble for
that but there's the entire season as
well and there are several games
per week so so really for college
basketball that's where testing is going
to be
i think even more critical in terms of
having daily tests or
or or you know results that you can get
right away so you know who's on and
and who's off that that's going to be
you know we have to have the point of
care testing if we're going to pull off
college basketball
doc thank you for your time and uh
continued good luck with
trying to i don't know lasso this but
i still would love to have the medical
community
with the acc sec big 12 pac 12 and big
ten
and do a town hall where we should be
able to hear
the information that's being exchanged
here i feel like as parents
as members of the media i appreciate you
coming on
why can't we pull that off well you know
i think it's a great question so
what we did on friday is as we actually
had two members of the ncaa
uh kobet medical advisory panel speaking
live to the entire nation with me and
they went through the deliberative
process of how we came to our decision
making
you know the autonomy 5 or the power 5
we've been meeting
every single week so every conference
has their medical advisory panel but
then they came
as one and yeah i think it's fair again
to to share the deliberative process on
on that and and
but it's what's been amazing is that the
scientists
really have agreed but when you have a
new situation
you can have scientific data and you
have one people that are interpreting it
this way and others that are
interpreting it that way and
you know if we assume good intent can
you still interpret things differently
well
actually history tells us that that's
the case
thank you doc good luck all right thank
you thanks for the opportunity to be
with you
it's dr brian haneline he's the ncaa
chief medical officer